en el vídeo anterior vimos que al añadir
zinc metálico en estado sólido a una
solución acuosa de sulfato de cobre el
zinc dona electrones que el cobre toma y
nos quedan cationes de zinc en la
solución que esencialmente se convierte
en una solución de sulfato de zinc y una
vez que el cobre gana dos electrones
pasa al estado sólido y precipita
separándose de la solución vimos que la
reacción del zinc sólido más el sulfato
de cobre en solución acuosa nos da la
precipitación de cobre sólido y la
solución acuosa de sulfato de zinc por
lo que el zinc ácido oxidado perdió dos
electrones pasó de un estado neutral a
uno positivo y el cobre de un estado
positivo a uno neutral así que el cobre
tomó ese par de electrones el zinc fue
oxidado por el cobre
y electrones y el cobre los gano y así
el cobre fue reducido por el zinc ganó 2
electrones del zinc algo fue oxidado y
algo fue reducido pero no sería
interesante si de alguna manera
pudiéramos separar estas reacciones
parciales y hacer que los electrones
viajen a través de un alambre bueno los
electrones viajando por un alambre es
algo común y algo común se puede
convertir en algo útil como electricidad
o un motor o luz eso es posible
habríamos construido algo parecido a una
batería y si conseguimos que funcione
entonces tendríamos una batería aquí les
tengo una imagen de lo que se llama
celda galvánica o también le dicen celda
voltaica lo que hace es precisamente
separar las reacciones parciales con un
alambre el zinc
donar sus electrones al cobre pero los
electrones son forzados a viajar por el
alambre para producir energía
veamos cómo funciona de este lado
tenemos zinc en estado sólido el zinc no
tiene problema en donar sus electrones y
el cobre no tiene problema en tomarlos
porque el cobre es más electro negativo
entonces el zinc puede donar dos
electrones y convertirse en un camión es
decir tener una carga positiva y
disolverse en el agua una vez que tiene
una carga positiva es muy fácil que se
disuelva en un solvente polar como el
agua pero a dónde van los electrones
como los electrones pueden ser donados
al cobre el zinc y el cobre son buenos
conductores de electricidad tienen
muchísimos electrones entonces los
electrones pueden viajar muy fácilmente
aquí van los electrones
el color verde representa a los
electrones que están viajando en el
alambre y llegan hasta el fondo de esta
placa de cobre que está en contacto con
la solución de sulfato de cobre ahora
tenemos un camión y un ión de cobre
cuando unión de cobre se encuentre con
estos electrones se los quedará y se
transformará cuando eso pase será unión
neutral y precipitará separándose de la
solución precipitara en la placa puede
ser que ahora se estén preguntando oye
qué pasa si tenemos muchos cationes de
zinc y si esta solución se vuelve muy
positiva entonces los electrones no
viajarán bueno si esto se vuelve muy muy
muy positivo al mismo tiempo todos los
cationes de cobre capturaría en
electrones y entonces la solución se
volverá más y más negativa
es decir tendrá más sulfato que cationes
de cobre que podríamos hacer para que
eso no pase tan rápido bueno podemos
usar uno de estos puentes es un puente
salino puente salino lo que hace es
ayudar a neutralizar el efecto que les
decía un puente salino no tiene líquido
en su interior porque así no funcionaría
se parece más a una sal pegajosa en este
caso nuestro puente salino es el sulfato
de sodio por cada molécula de sulfato
tenemos una unión de sulfato y dos
cationes de sodio que es lo que pasará
aquí bueno como esto se vuelve cada vez
más positivo por la aparición de los
iones de zinc los iones negativos del
sulfato adentro del puente querrán salir
mientras que los que están en esta
solución dejarán a sus amigos y querrán
entrar al puente los que ya estén en el
puente saldrán a la solución con el zinc
de la misma manera el sodio ayuda en la
neutralización irá en esta dirección y
neutralizar a cualquier negatividad esto
mantendrá ambas soluciones neutralizadas
en caso de que se vuelvan muy negativas
o muy positivas permitiendo que continúe
el flujo de energía y que sea útil